so here we go people already on here I
became a fan hi fans here with Tyrone
today is right how many guests do we got
coming in how many guests says zero but
I see a whole bunch of comments this is
a lie this is a lie 21 new viewers let's
get this broadcast going all right guys
we're gonna be a little bit chiller
today since you're gonna get a real
version of us I guess all right so the
tip I got was we should shout out people
who are tuning in um maliki em yeah it's
starting damn right it's starting maliki
em yeah Sawyer TC I'm glad you're a fan
hey Josh H hey Josh ish they've done a
live stream ever game for gaming though
not for QA no - laser Arsenal wants us
to kiss now oh no no whoo Tony Tom said
whoo Tyrone Orion good lord I know I
know this is this is exactly what you
two have been waiting for us the
ultimate heterosexual homosexual 3
Brandon SS Tyrone and Ryan are the best
reactors ever
okay we got a Kurt we got a question Zoe
anger hey Ryan who do you think is the
most beautiful actor Ryan Gosling
hands-down Ryan Gosling whoa actor yeah
come on who's the most beautiful actor
to you I don't find me beautiful
what about actress then that's the hard
one
we had to improvise things on the spot
for your channel be prolonged or Eva
Longoria that is a beautiful one I'd
have to go with Veronica six outs as the
most beautiful actress I know that's
right baby who's the champ create ass
just like your ass my girlfriend and
Tyrone have the best asses I've ever
seen Jonathan G what we'll both he be
doing if it wasn't YouTube oh that's a
great question
- good wish I probably be in sales
really still in sales doing something
technically everything we do is sales
yeah so I think like I don't know it
would be something sales related where
or opening my own business because I
don't like working for anyone
I am very good told what to do so if it
feels different being your own boss now
right yes you have to find something to
do with yourself
yeah whoa we got a hundred sixty people
tuning in right now let's see oh there's
like so many questions coming in and
retire around choose one who's the
ugliest actor ever that's the ugliest
actor ever the boil factory have you
ever seen weird science
if you seem weird sinuses a point where
these crazy new bikers crash their party
there's a bald guy there with pointy
ears
he'll that already sounds gross via the
ugliest actor um Taylor Ilana
yeah hey riot and tyro designs bikers if
you watch any of the new read actors who
do you think is an upcoming reactor che
che for sure
I think Shay's gonna be the [ __ ] you
like I'm Dante I know him so he Dante's
got a lot of town I like I'm Dante -
he's great yeah it's a shame I'm Dante
an office on should be bigger
he should be but he's not I don't know
why I heard me Japan he landed down on
ladies it was like go zero zero he's
pretty big down there that's listen he
was at a racist rip he told me yeah was
not racist cause I'm black so yeah you
could get away with anything any read
any race Tyrone can get away with whoa
so many questions
hey baby can't say hi in the Q&A someone
wants you to say hi mr. name I her Oh
will you stick it in his butt I told you
get comments Ringo told you get come
with your comments we can't do that
alive it's illegal so that's why we're
gonna do it tonight
dead-house Eisenberg Tyrone how many
sexual references is Ryan made so far
um 305 300 is something like that Ryan
talked to Tyrone about how he plays
fallout for seven hours hey Tyrone you
know how you play fallout for seven
hours mm-hmm
do you really have nothing else better
to do for seven hours than place all out
for that day I definitely did that and
if I did it it didn't occur to me
fallout 4 is the [ __ ] yes
all right so that day it was [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] money who just played his
goddamn game yeah I wish I would see
which I had your lifestyle sometimes but
I'm in love and that's better that's
better than anything else uh Tyrone what
is your favorite game oh uh how good
Street Fighter 2 Street Fighter 2 nice
that's a good game that's a good game I
like Mega Man X a lot growing up it was
pretty good
yeah Super Nintendo was the [ __ ]
Mendeley a token yeah oh yeah when you
got another delicate can upgrade yeah
that was the ship what's your favorite
movie The Matrix
Superman Christopher Reeve 1970s version
yeah and Veronica's here for whoever
asked to see her right what's your
favorite Eminem song beautiful oh oh
guys we got a number one fan he just
sent in 50 likes
Shawn ramble you our number one fan you
are awesome I love you
Shawn Rempel Tyrone did not move love
you Brian traveled got a private message
from a person who said they love me and
I just forgot their name so sorry
genau Chettiar he's the key thing so
they're happy to see bro
- Nathan Rho has five has been asking
repetitively ranked the Star Wars films
the second one
everyone Empire creamy Empire not
Episode two Empire Strikes Back
everyone that I'm ago as so - is the
best yeah yeah episode 2 is the best one
it's absolutely the Clones was such a
feeding Christensen so how is Tyrone in
bed um gentle you can always a lot more
gentle than I expected him to be you
know you'd expect like some rough like
oh I'm gonna make on your way good yeah
yeah oh oh whoa whoa we got we got more
faves here we got more faves these guys
are throwing it likes three Archer eight
190 519 bars dude I don't forgot what it
means on you now but that that's some
raisin stuffs eight bars sounds new kids
New Kids on the Block six fat roulette a
bad roulette you two real right right
you and Tyrone shave your balls and
we'll time I'll get some orange juice no
my balls are smooth so calming is a
hazard
I must shave my balls every day I'm a
ball shaver it grows repetitively none
around the crotch like above the penis
but it's all on the ball sack it's like
I'm going completely bald everywhere
else the ball sack full of hair
pretty fancy saturation he has like
connections
so sometimes agent waxing please what
Tyrone's making to find it you're
supposed to laugh when Tyra makes a joke
what are you doing here if you're not
laughing what Tyrone makes the funny
[ __ ] show will y'all react to videos
yes we just felt super Tyrone's to for
mine they'll be up probably late tonight
or tomorrow sometime
Nathan robot and it's a lot I don't
Tyron since Woody's is wrong uncut
yeah mine will be edited out many times
I got my solutions but I am somebody
else how much you fanboy doubt me yeah
both of you when you guys saw each other
fanboy out yeah you're excited you're
invited really I was really yes we
knocked over Skype and stuff it's like
it's like when you start doing online
dating and then you finally meet in
person it's like look each other like
it's so weird it's like you're in front
of me it's so strange
it's like but I feel like I know you
love you to hate you jeno do chedi said
hate you why why why would you hate me
hate you
yeah me block bed loser blocking him I
don't know he donated money okay Narwhal
he donated four hundred forty nine bars
dude you are awesome I love it mmm page
lonely 20 bars hey guys what are the
bars mean Veronica be mad if you left
her for Tyrone Nicole G would you be I'd
be [ __ ] pissed off
I'll be really [ __ ] pissed oh I'm not
gay but if I was you can't be met
because you know it's another man I
can't take you down I could take your
ads battery I'm just saying that don't
you don't be mad because like I always
thought if a woman left me for another
woman it's like well I can't compete for
that I'm not too sore vagina what can I
do
okay Paul I mean I didn't write in
Tyrone from for Archer 8 1 9 to Ryan and
Tyrone who is the most famous person you
have met well I didn't mean them with
the rock literally about five ten feet
from at a bodybuilding contest nice
right their biggest day I don't know who
the biggest actor I would have met is
Bill Goldberg and then Holly man you met
Halle Berry yeah mm-hmm two minutes you
need the rest as your gorgeous thing I
told have an arm wrestling match Erin
moan music let's do this let's go for
real
let's go for real ok I want you to take
all you have to have a hard surface we
have a hard surface all right you can't
see the frame I can't get this this is a
go you're going for real are you I'm
really are you really going
terribly how my no because you are
owning so no oh [ __ ] [ __ ] yours
messing around told you go joy let me a
kick Jada bro dab bro blow me kiss are
you okay with that yeah I'm okay with
that
don't say blow em to you well it is all
these people doing in all these bars
thanks guys apparently bars equals money
we're making money can someone tell us
what that means you guys got a bromance
they do sixteen rod yeah we do
I totally respect it to noids not me 1 2
3 4 so what do you all do the [ __ ] is
that supposed to mean
what we're youtubers are youtubers
that's all we do I love you to live
since 5 sister B hey Ryan lady be in
Tyrone if you can anything given under
channel what would it be on what would
be different on your channel what would
you add to your channel it's a good
question he used to call me vagina
vagina 6 this
he finally stopped calling me that when
he started dating a year ago vagina
could shine economy you can make these
jokes that was great
I'm probably joining up - tag no don't
do that I what was the question
uh yeah what would you change different
about your channel oh I would marry
Lawrence I get that a lot
you know I I wouldn't change anything
people's all we have suggestions you see
you can do that if you want to know any
subscribers I've been doing fine going
it the way I'm almost there wouldn't
change a thing
I mean it's working what we're doing and
I want to add more sketches next year
that's one of my plans more sketches
much traveling yeah they'll be fine
I would love to do a traveling vlog oh
yeah that'd be fun
give me a lot of fun hell yeah I may do
a road trip and
logging out when Sean Rempel you are the
[ __ ] dude
archery 192 sent us a private message
Ryan and I wrote a feeling awesome
thanks man thanks you're awesome too
Jihan 31 what was the first impression
you guys had to each other um we're not
that different than Heidi yeah I know
when we met yeah he's taller than it
he's a little taller than me are you
intimidated by that no no II give me
along in armwrestling just like what you
saw in me no I thought it was always
like maybe my height a little shorter
this is why you peers on camera everyone
thinks I'm six-three but I'm not allowed
to lie usually when I'm on camera right
now I'm being like forced to yeah we
cookie madam I was like a little higher
there look up now my eyes are always a
little higher you know Gennadiy Chetty I
actually love you guys thanks for
clearing that up Jenner do Chetty let's
see come on come on sorry there's so
many questions rolling and sorry miss
them has she keeping me me t me tell you
on Wizards she was on Wizards of Waverly
Place that showed Selena Gomez really
plays everyone's heard of Wizards of
Waverly Place like oh well generally
directing videos Jhon says Tyrone Magnus
love you favorite Marvel movie angelahr
favorite Marvel movie hope it was a guy
or girl no feel fine tomorrow
Captain America Winter Soldier or the
Avengers is my favorite Marvel movie if
we're talking about the Marvel Cinematic
Universe I keep thinking that cameras on
okay yeah the Marvel Cinematic Universe
I would have to say that one or it would
be x-men 2 if we're just talking about
all the Marvel movies x-men not include
now don't like your movies singer just
the last one the returns or Days of
Future past days of future being like
that I like a surprise I liked it but it
was so depressing
by I get what you're saying Yeah right
in Tyrone you should do a skit physical
gamers mmm oh we should do a skin
what would the skit be I know what
improve every great plot has a what-if
thing to it you know like spider-man
what if someone was bitten by a
radioactive spider um what if Tyrone
Veronica and I had a threesome I think
we could get a good plot there I don't
even think we need to really have a
script I think we could just improvise
this right cuz really go yeah I think it
would be good I think it'd be good just
really wrong you know we need a flop
girl we need a flat girl a girl what
exactly nevermind a fluff is you know
Mouse the taken King 21 the net Veronica
you look like Vanessa Hudgens she's
beautiful
thank you a mark and is Ryan hey John
Cena as much as Tyrone definitely not
temping ryan those I kind of know who
John Cena is he's the wrestler
I saw the prank call you didn't reaction
Ryan and Tyrone favorite superhero
except Batman Superman
hashkee me D I like Nightwing or flu
you've ever was well Fantastic Four oh
yeah fantastic fourth yeah Ryan's
identity thief hated that one too
Jay Dubrow wants Ariana included our
threesome guys who's Ariana
I mean anniversary she's a Jewish girl
known for her huge wreck what funny
Angie's money more than joining rash
that she's funny
okay you said that after the language oh
yeah she's got a channel Oh check her
out now never for a while
yo thanks for the recent shoutout Ryan
what do you think of Tyrone
participating in Mary Jane festivities
that means I marijuana
Tyrone would not smoke the marijuana I
offered him I presented a pound of
marijuana I said you could have as much
as you want and he said no i am a
magnesite i'm
she come allergens but he actually
really said I'm allergic
sorry can't smoke who do you think
should it be the next u.s. president
three already promised Trump you think
so drunk no he's the man literally dude
you could be strong now but we're all
and done when she gets angry there's
like well because I know a lot of it
really yeah I'm not super political but
I know it's Trump's been saying a lot of
things
this guy just some guy just said this
right even live okay ready for this
ready for this Tyrone's that I have a
good peek what's a peek we got pretty
yeah I think is bare bicep to me right
this guy has to see my bicep oh yeah
yeah yeah so fights on them all day oh
yes XS they see vaginal sex
Wow your parents named you properly big
grand ass I love Mexican so do I
articles what are your favorite DBZ
characters right in Tyrone honestly not
that familiar with DBZ don't worry I'll
put into depth I've done this video
favorite one two three Vegeta Vegeta
Goku and Gohan nice one to Italy
Mason glow and DJ what movie are you
most excited for in 2016 I forgot the
name already know who he said what are
you most excited for for 2016 what movie
oh there might be Superman Batman V
Superman six have question I think I'll
most of awards you know what's weird
even though I had my complaints about I
know I had a lot of complaints about the
last trailer I would still say BBS
long looking porch and I was waiting for
forever yeah that's the one I'm looking
forward to most let's get it over so
Deadpool's another one
but now I'm still some BBS is forming
you are my favorite reactors Veronica
you're hot from Archer 8192 Veronica is
hot I approve of this comment and okay
why doesn't Jerry get any love Jacob are
even no Darius and he's even seen Jerry
loves you
he's a co-creator of the real rejects oh
the other one that was like calling
Gosling no not Gosling
Captain America handsome handsome man
yeah yeah I'm worried
Wow like Ryan Jerry just doesn't really
take much credit he's like not the one
that is going to he's not quiet like
Ryan like Abbott and Costello sort of
medically talented and super funny Ryan
Platts so where are you guys right now
we are in New Jersey I came all the way
to the East Coast I have family out here
and Tyrone was about to about two and a
half hours away he drove all the way
here just to hang out with us that's how
that's how he that's the type of guy I
am
yeah sweet it's like a big cuddly teddy
bear yes I approved yeah so funny -
hello from Iceland J Hans 11 how you
doing very green five Narwhal uniform
well Marvel or DC I still need a
chiropractor seeing them twice
twice a week until he says I don't have
to yeah yeah you take a number
Zoey anger who has the best laugh from
all III I have it I got people say I
have a blonde hair laughing yeah he's
got a pretty intense lap is pretty
explosive yeah
I'm really fast but you crack up you're
like you don't really make noise but
your expression is like it's fine dude
it just tilted a little bit Oh as I was
in a full Ryan a fight Tyrone that's
okay
no it's got matrix moves man I can find
either Jack in well I can't use that
word I need to upload the Frog if I
tried yeah Saudi Arabia to Majeed seven
and nail hello Saudi Arabia Arabia ah
okay Tyra do you're laughing I was used
in a that was used in a vine what a
laugh that was me well my legs yeah
sorry Tyrone now we need you to make us
a gem Tyrone make us laugh
show us your humor Tyrone okay hey
haters side down because I'm saying
Superman will crush Batman let's not
make it about you man
it's about us it's about us the bolt
Factory who's your favorite youtuber
Jeremy Jones for me and actually to be
totally honest there's two channels like
there's three channels I follow Jeremy
Jones honest trailer strange junkies and
Tyra madness is this that as far as my
channels go yeah
everything else I just wait for you guys
to read less than vinden I'll check it
out do any of you watch Batman V
Superman what's your favorite video
you've ever reacted to hatred has that
one of the most should one of us
shocking content videos of every single
feature probably uh receipts us receipt
is [ __ ] you're nothing you stood Spanish
guy that has hilarious laughs oh the
other spider-man yeah yeah oh yeah I
know you're a featured a lot I'll skip
for that yeah here we see that one time
home is losing a kid on that ones it was
so every comment of mine on my video it
was like this video where they like this
person was speaking Spanish but they
like put subtitles
the new spiderman casting on it instead
of the actual really one head I kept lag
he was like losing his [ __ ] and every
one of my comments on my video was
Tyrone's was better this reactions such
check outs high road magazines in a
chime it's working that was good good
call God what are your thoughts on Jared
Leto Joker from archery 192 I think he
looks good it's promising I think it's
not something where I'm like oh no we'll
have something to worry about
I'm not yeah good but you know it's like
Jesse Eisenberg as Lex Luthor is causing
people concerns like very 50/50 on all
my comments section of soon it's not
look smooth son okay no we'll see shout
out to London Hasmik et Cie g25 5:09
what is your scariest experience with
YouTube hmm my first copyright strike
huh
Deadpool leaked footage test reaction I
had to at one point there's they're like
well your game or your channel shut yeah
that's why you guys should start
building on different platforms
you know besides YouTube everywhere else
you can't really make an income though
you feel another kind of science that
you can well there's at most sites equal
those I told my mother I would never did
yeah and I told my mom I would dude I'm
very disappointed when I didn't get into
it yeah got an illogical 6 dos not doing
porn lender 7 which superhero fits your
personality my favorite superhero is not
this superhero but I think if I was to
be one of them I think my Tony Stark
personality would come out of me oh he
does remind me it's on yeah
some ways he makes his jokes and says
certain things to be sorry I said
Veronica make more music I I know I just
been kind of a funk lately and I haven't
been really going as far as I'm like me
black music is the fall you need a funk
girl you need them for this guy through
phase in my life but I'm coming back
soon with my music but check out my
vlogs I've been uploading for the past
couple days I thought he said the n-word
the flick psychos what's your favorite
dance singers what's your favorite band
or singer Michael Jackson Michael
Jackson yeah hold on
yeah nice dog I really really like Tom
York and uh for his amazing you do yeah
son hunk oh I'm Radiohead I knew that
yeah all right beautiful I like that
eerie kind of experimental sound
summerhall I like um I like the Red Hot
Chili Peppers and Eminem you don't like
a man do ya like him yeah I feel a
little extra but yeah like okay um my
movie sorry just tell me if I'm
interrupting my movie it's supposed to
come out in 2016 in seven cities we
don't know exactly where yet we know
it's gonna be in New York LA in Chicago
but other than that I'm not sure but
I'll let you guys know five Archer 8190
I think Jeremy Jones is watching that
would be cool yeah I wouldn't I would
fly at $4 Jeremy Jones lives but he was
like dude I want to collab with you but
you have to come to me I would totally
throw down for a plane ticket to go work
with him how many all let me know
comment below let me know yeah Tyrone
Orion are there any celebrities you
would like to meet also greens from
Puerto Rico I would like to meet um
Gosling for sure and Mel Gibson
definitely Conan O'Brien
Jennifer Lance Rock for now to defeat it
I must destroy the rock they're going to
only be even one Rock DJ Garcia Rey
favorite youtuber I just said you're
John's come on come on let's get some
good why are you got an actor Tyrone um
damar that's not true he is an actor he
just you want to know what that's like
saying I'm gonna stir this now it's like
saying you sang it to your musician I
sing another music okay so if she
doesn't have an album out you say well
when are you gonna be in musician it's
like well she still is grace because she
hasn't put one out yeah I haven't been
anything major are you going to start
acting again I'm still learning how to
read how these things work
crazy 22.9 capers I wish I knew at the
bars met fine now do you prefer CGI or
hand-drawn animation I prefer hand-drawn
um okay my man answer these questions
faster any of you three have any movie
or TV deals in the works um I had an
opportunity for a porn joke but I took
too long
ah ah too long like Tyrone yeah as far
as any movies um I've been contacted for
a few things so far guys just trying to
figure things out process yes the
process a lot of pressure like I just
get started on wet so easy yeah I didn't
independent film a while ago and it's
gone through some film festivals so far
won some awards and next year it will be
having a theatrical release cool and
here four zero three five zero right -
so Tyrone
when are you coming to LA I'm sorry - it
seems and I've leaned into be an entire
Oh
raise the black
right billion oh yeah everyone always
blames me man even when I was blames me
never people act out everyone's like raw
and spoiled and brings it out of me like
I have to be dirty
cuz it's never okay with that oh I feel
like I gotta see other legs up and Iike
like talking deep deep gotta keep
talking but there's a lot of questions
were missing you so many something but
yeah whoa so many comments would you
guys ever do a comedy together if you
offered the og true hell yeah I'll do a
comedy with Tyrone
ah I actually oh yeah we make a great
bunny movie I have a have a television
show no no no yes partners partner we
should play two cops who are partners
but are also in love with each other no
we're good yeah Martinizing crying oh
yeah we should like both have what Oh
should we both have wine this is now be
great that we could break though hankins
we learn that like against Andrea four
zero three five seven
Tyron when are you coming to LA yeah
you're not sure are you Sonia counts
crash on the couch yeah no we're gonna
get a two-bedroom soon you crash in the
second bedroom cool
yeah man have company over love how Ryan
makes time around uncomfortable you're
Henry well do better on how there's more
people here I'm visiting my family right
now so it's inside later I her bliss
penguin love you guys hi Tyrone love you
I'm to love you guys but you wanted to
give a special we're going to tie round
things stutter lacking when it done with
that loud noises next term in movie town
should be Terminator
I should be done it was stronger Reiner
Tyrell be prime o8 you met
the arm-wrestle match there's a disk DP
1 what is the next crazy Veronica sketch
probably in January or February to be
honest crazy I'm not going to be crazy
in that one though
yeah you are we're both are yeah but not
like Tyrone's in it just the three of us
she's gonna be bad at one shot you are
gonna add on that asset that myself
right now
well restrain yourself all right you
Tyra
you seem Shawn indeed Wiley am do you
plan on having kids Tyrell someday maybe
someday I love a good dad he'd be a
great dad
yeah he probably had their pain in the
kids all probably have a big penis just
like you or a huge vagina yeah okay
bliss penguin ship time underbars thanks
man
I uh I asked you Oh Tyrone first
impression Orion no just like a Bobby B
there we go yeah well we are I said it
before I was like a really solid first
take your hat off is what I look like
right now easily you I have ugly hair
right now mm-hmm
no I don't feel attractive I run your
like Sowell group you go to barber yes
you go to a barber yes everybody that
now I'm like I'm like the only guy who
doesn't go to a barber you don't made
this for riot yes he is cute our day 192
favorite comic book casting love all you
we love you too
comic book casting I would have to say
don't you start I thought he nailed it
oh yeah
Ryan get a haircut whoa whoa we're gonna
take someone down a [ __ ] neck here said
Tyrone is boring Thank You dick way to
handle em and right I don't care what
you think oh right
come in man come at me you're gonna get
high school era mode musically get on
schmoes no again are you talking to me
or Tyra
oh well no private number yet take that
last time I got this feeling all the
Avengers are on the screen together for
the first time I'm glad that you could
compare us you know to that thank you
thank you
um one of you guys choose a question
they're just rolling in like crazy no
that's comic book you've ever read oh I
like the Dark Knight Returns also like
to Killing Joke there were two good kind
of books I think mine was Batman year
one that was good yeah I forgot about
that I liked the other one a lot your
one was and I liked Nightwing the hunt
for work a lot okay are they arguing
about this favorite directors eyes again
thank you people got mad at me because I
said that Sylvester Stallone was one of
my favorites I've always done some good
films I said Michael Bay I think Michael
Bay has done some head I don't care what
ones he's done that you guys hated he's
still done some good ones but I had
mentioned James Cameron Cameron first um
Steven Spielberg George Lucas you know
you guys are like Christopher Nolan yeah
I would have to say I do like you know
some classics Tarantino I think Scorsese
is the most if people go mad that I
didn't mention yeah Lee and Mary don't
mention their favorite like yeah I like
Scorsese a lot I think he's the most
consistent um like David Fincher and
with those brothers that matrix I like
them yeah one of them's a girl now well
yeah I guess that one a lot of Larry
wachowski became a lot of which as the
year clearly joking right no you are
insulting a whole and I know ago I just
didn't know
what deal with Nestle neck yaar what's
your favorite TV show of all time
Breaking Bad and um friends oh I had
that's my past it's too hard too hard
yeah yeah - I'm not going to touch that
uh it was too hard but if it was a
little looser okay Oh Nicole gee what's
your favorite Ryan Gosling movie of all
time
oh I love drive I really a spy drive or
goes all in that place move aa
girlfriend hasn't seen drive yeah
willing to stomp the guy's dead yeah I
know drivers what about her place beyond
the pines you love that I watched fear
The Walking Dead and then I recently
started watching The Walking Dead I am
hooked now I think I used to hate
zombies well how many people are on here
yeah like two walking good like I watch
that I'm an imbecile seven people I just
can't read this all right guys we're
gonna talk for five more minutes because
I have to have dinner and Tyrone has a
two and half hour drive back favorite
comedian Louie CK Dave Attell I was
thinking Dave Attell but I like Bo
Burnham TV Bo Burnham is great I'm a big
Mike Epps guy too
I like like this damn and they have some
hard questions
duh any advice for starting a reaction
channel - Sam G yeah be your so be
yourself embrace yourself I have a sane
I came up with the only way to be unique
is be yourself
that's why unique starts with the letter
U he
that right does it exactly that way
people always laugh at it but I'm like
it's a cruel thing they said like paper
with it written a nice pursuit like some
black-and-white photo me talking about
is your profile shot at me point yeah
are you a gamer Ryan off and on gamer
and I'm not a gamer either I'm the guy
that plays games I'm used to be maybe
I'll be coming to Victor he'll really
wants to know if we watch the NFL no no
no I'm on to you no no I I watch youtube
videos and trailers in porn and pawn
right and Veronica's video she sends to
me when she's away from home yeah did
she's trying to keep yeah don't be shy
room lads and that's I Ron anybody but
Tyrone anybody but five hundred sixty
thousand subscribers he is more than a
human comment about power
what would be your recommendation it
would be Tyrone and I reacting so
heavily to a video would I think our
record rack a video he would be a react
off we're slowly body parts from our
face starts falling off then might be in
our heads just explode yeah that's all
this Tyrone five left four foot seven
you've gotta be six foot or I'm five
foot eleven I'm five-eleven yeah or five
eleven and a half I think but I know I'm
always around five eleven ok um favorite
UFC fighter or why don't have either
Anderson someone thinks I should be
Wonder Woman gonna sleep no Jay Roberts
three five nine
here's your shout out you rock Nathaniel
himself up
what too many movies all right guys we
have to canvas in just a second I
unfortunately am NOT a gamer Artie's
networking vodka as a roommate who said
that I lost it uh 18 jung jae-young one
two three uh who are kinky to Omashu do
two like Chewbacca we get on my nerves
like everything you say sounds the same
you're communicating nothing dude one
loud you're shedding every where are you
- at least Queens he communicates the
next day on he fixes it Chewie helps get
things done those Fixman be primer wait
this is real it's in the hyperdrive yes
they asked me to hug Tyrone well he was
just hugging you tight rodica useless
former enemy would you ever be bounding
the act in a film folks I've done that
what do you want to know if I were to be
bound and gagged in a film
it depends it depends it sirens in it
with us
just do it Tyrone come on just kiss
Tyrone on the cheek I'm not gonna do
that
well not gonna do that no I I am so like
I'm right I have literally zero against
gay people but when it comes to kissing
a guy on the cheek I'm like oh I can't
do that it grosses me out
dressing me out for some reason ah
Tyrone should be a black Adam was that
me black black Adams easy care oh now
the rock fits Black Adam much better
than Hamby leo all you guys are my
heroes
thanks man Ryan and Tyrone penetrance
a 1909
I'm only a nine I'm not a 10 thank you
someone wants you to slap me do it
Tyrone come on don't be a [ __ ] you
little [ __ ] bet you want to slap me
don't you [ __ ] yeah
be careful Ryan and Tyrone I think the
better be careful of me how does it
finally feel the meat
it feels good 10 rather comfortable Oh
NL a weight an L a 10 was that mean
that's a good chain hey so my Jerry
that's like you gotta say that out here
well is the same that's kind of like
your uh I can't think of the the right
city right now but it's like yo she's
like yeah you guys feel like City Kansas
a Kansas nine but in five yeah cuz you
know you're hot from the bad woman get
the LA I think that's how this thing
goes India on fleek one you should kiss
Tyrone you can kiss Tyrone on the cheek
okay any permission to kiss her Allah -
you can kiss Tyrone on the cheap do it
do it I want to watch I want she water
oh my god buddy I was planted you a
sketch when he comes to LA sometimes I
were a veronica's at ten Ryan's of four
oh I know trust me I ask myself every
day
um hey how old are y'all all right guys
38:25 but I'm a 46 year old down there
slightly gray anyway guys yeah thank you
for tuning in for this QA we're not used
to talking to so many people at one time
appreciate all the bars from
everyone and all the messages you guys
Rock I don't know some other nice things
that youtubers say and hey somebody add
you guys for subscribing all that stuff
wait somebody asked if I could do a
tutorial for for universe and I've never
thought about doing a tutorial for my
own original music before but maybe I'll
think about it
oh thank you very long day I know come
on my channel and your Jionni I'm sorry
I would never disrespect you like that
on your channel thank you guys for
letting me crash your little you what is
this you pawn you now begin porn is real
for now yeah you point out someone said
kill Ryan and kiss Tyrone oh hey I hate
I hate the self promotion thing but I'm
doing a vlog for hopefully every single
day of our trip we're gonna be out here
for a week and we hunt we hung out with
Tyrone a little bit today so we got some
like behind the scenes stuff check out
my channel veronika six those oceans a
bish Nick yard how rich are all of you
never at like 20 dollars it's very rich
I blow all my money but I'm still rich
by the end of the day like I make up for
it the next day once I'm out of money by
accumulating trust me yeah I'm well
taken care of
alright guys we really gotta go Emily
get rid of fire this is fun I will
return can't guarantee Tyrone will be
here but encourage Tyrone to get one of
these yeah thanks guys
you all Rock love all you all whoo 1
million subscribers so many fell me too